venom 2 had just the most insane
post-credits scene you know what's more
insane than the post-credits scene in
venom the fact that everybody's getting
it wrong okay so here's the thing here's
what's actually going on here this is
nuts a few things to know one the
obligatory review of venom two we
laughed we cried had some cool fight
scenes movie was awesome moving on
number one patrick mulligan's gonna
become toxin who's toxin toxin is like
the offspring of carnage in the same way
that eddie brock gave birth or venom
gave birth to carnage carnage gives
birth to toxin toxins more powerful than
both carnage and venom in fact in the
comics they had to team up to try to
stop toxin and then eddie brock
basically adopted him and then talked
and bonded to a cop and became a good
guy and a story the second thing venom
proposes a mind meld with eddie brock
and eddie's like this is kind of cool he
wants to know the whole history of the
symbiotes what does venom say your mind
can't handle the 80 billion years of
symbiote history across multiverses
symbiotes are multiversal why does that
matter because i don't know whether
we'll actually see it or not but it'd be
awesome to see null the symbiote god
who's in all the simian god no the
symbiote god is basically the guy who
created the symbiotes right they're
basically living abyss if you could take
darkness and give it a physical form
that's symbiotes now ultimately null
fought the celestials he was basically
defeated he was imprisoned inside his
own planet which was encased by the
semis that he had created which had
basically turned against him in the
process and then they basically started
traveling across the universe and even
the multiverse binding themselves to
different hosts and different things
happen the reference to the multiverse
by venom is exceedingly important here
why because as you guys know from the
biggest part of the post-credits scene
eddie brock's sitting in his place they
kind of begin the mind mail but it
doesn't really actually start instead
there's a bright flash of light
everything changes and eddie brock wakes
up in a place that is similar to the
hotel he was in before but just small
little differences here and there along
with basically a guy in his underwear
brushing his teeth who's like why the
hell are you here but on the tv is the
news broadcast of jay jonah jameson and
this is where everybody's getting it
wrong everybody is hypothesizing this
idea that what happened with eddie brock
is a result of the spell that was cast
by doctor strange right that the spell
was cast things went wrong and basically
eddie brock has been yanked into the mcu
no that is not happening how do we know
that's not the case because even if we
take the most
elemental aspects of this video right
look at this whole thing you have jay
jonah jameson making the broadcast that
tom holland is spider-man it's an
exclusive and it's breaking news
basically meaning it just happened so
what this means is this broadcast that
we're seeing on tv happened within maybe
an hour or two of the events of the end
of spider-man far from home when tom
holland basically killed mysterio
although i still say he's alive and then
the daily bugle broadcast that
information out to the world because of
the message that was sent to them by
mysterio so if we look at this and we
see everything that we're seeing in
spider-man 3 that the timelines don't
match up some amount of time had to have
passed maybe a couple days maybe a
couple weeks whatever it is but some
period of time had passed between when
spider-man's identity was made public to
the world and when he went to go see
doctor strange there's points where he's
in school we see he's hanging out with
mj so like it's not as though like his
identity was dumped to the world and
then like three hours later he's in the
sanctum sanctorum doc you gotta do
something about this man so this
broadcast happened almost immediately
after far from home basically if the
spell hasn't been cast by doctor strange
yet then how could it be that eddie was
yanked into the mcu the answer to that
question ladies and gentlemen
wow loki okay one of the theories that
we had when it came to this this whole
thing the multiverse coming back in the
loki tv show right one of the things
that we pointed out is that universes
were crossing over with each other right
you guys remember we talked about that
we showed what it looked like when the
multiverse was coming back and you had
universes growing and then you had
universes passing through them so on and
so forth one of the things that we had
talked about in spider-man 3 and
possibly could have been the spell of
doctor strange or possibly even
something else maybe it's not that the
spell went awry maybe it's because of
the events of loki is that the marvel
cinematic universe is just passing
through other realities right it's the
explanation we gave for how it is that
you see alfred molina's doctor octopus
then you see like jamie foxx's electro
from some alternate reality willem
dafoe's green goblin because they're
passing through universes and along the
way they're meeting these various people
now again whether that's actually true
or not i don't know but this really
seems to lend credence to it right that
much like we saw with the end of loki
and the multiverse coming back and
universes passing through each other
this seems to be a result of that that
eddie brock's universe his venomverse is
passing through the marvel cinematic
universe how long he'll stay there we
don't know we don't know if it'll be the
equivalent of him like hopping off the
train and staying in that universe or if
he just kind of keeps on passing through
and that's that although
now that i think about it the big
question to ask here
will we see tom hardy's venom in the
future of the mcuc that's the question
to ask that i'm not even 100 sure about
i mean it would be cool but it would be
amazing i mean here's the thing i feel
like this is something that you don't
walk back right like sony doesn't like
throw venom into the mcu in this way and
then we see everything unfold on doctor
strange too and then everything goes
back to normal like i feel like we're
experiencing a paradigm shift if i'm
being honest with you guys and i've said
this before i feel like what's happening
in doctor strange too is basically a
consolidation of all the marvel
properties whether they're owned by
marvel studios and disney or not under
the singular marvel cinematic universe
landscape or whatever it is and it's not
the first time we've seen that right
like there have been stories for example
after doctor octopus took over the body
of peter parker became superior
spider-man and then peter got his body
back dr octopus created a clone body for
himself and then he was spider-man out
in san francisco so it's entirely
possible that you could basically see
this whole landscape where like eddie
brock is venom he's in the mcu as part
of the mcu but he just fights and does
whatever he does out in san francisco
and stays there and it's only every so
often that you see him go to new york or
something like that but we know that
like the new avengers are coming and if
i'm being honest with you guys i think
venom would be a great addition to the
marvel cinematic universe as part of the
new avengers right like you guys sean
chi or shang chi whatever you want to
call him then you got venom you'll
probably have tall hardy spider-man who
will continue on in his role as
spider-man as part of the new avengers
and then whoever else they feel like
bringing in as time goes on but i feel
like he'd be a fantastic addition to the
team if for no other reason than the
comedic relief and i know that venom is
not necessarily supposed to be a comedic
character but honestly i love what
sony's done with him i love the way that
venom's been created by sony in their
movies so i kind of want to see that
going
i really don't want to see that change
but i feel like he'd make a great
addition so that's my question to you
guys would you guys want to see venom on
a new avengers team in the marvel
cinematic universe or do you want to see
venom out there by himself basically
just doing his own thing just kind of
existing in isolation away from
everybody you might see some stuff
involving events going on in the greater
mcu on like a tv screen when he's at a
bar or like when he passes by some store
that sells tvs if they even do that in
san francisco and like you see something
on the tv itself right so you know that
stuff is still going on but aside from
like some crossover event you don't
really see eddie brock interacting with
the rest of the mcu honestly i think
it'd be a waste if they did that and i
and again i don't really see them going
back on this so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments because
i'm really curious what your idea is
about this but this is huge guys this is
very very very big but i i feel like no
one's talking about this right
everyone's like oh well it's got to be a
spell cast by doctor strange it does not
have to be tied in directly to the
events of spider-man 3. would it be cool
if it was sure but i think it'd be far
more significant and far more notable if
it's tied into the events of loki
because what it means is venom's
involvement in the mcu is not limited to
whatever spider-man happens to be doing
it's much much bigger than that so again
i'm excited man like this is this is
i was man when i was in that theater i
jumped up right i stood up like mariah
will tell you i was just like what and
it took everything i could to not like
lose my mind in this movie theater just
start freaking out like oh my god this
this post credit scene is everything
dude it was so cool and that's one of
the great things about this man is that
if you if you look like in this
post-credits scene like i was ready for
one right i was like okay there's got to
be a post credit scene here and i was
literally just analyzing everything i
possibly could as fast as i possibly
could right the symbiotes are
multiversal they exist across different
universes here's the other thing too
here's another thing too right here's
here's here's here's the other thing too
right the symbiotes share a hive mind
right the simu
this is going to blow your mind the
symbiotes share a hive mind right yes
that's one of the things that venom
established the symbiotes share a hive
mind the hive mind expands across the
multiverse 80 billion years of history
sam raimi's spider-man is still in
continuity and that includes spider-man
3 when topher grace got the venom
symbiote so here's the question you have
to ask because venom tom hardy venom
looked like it recognized spider-man
right he looks at him he's like that guy
right and he says it with a kind of
voice like i know that guy right he
doesn't really say like i know that guy
but he's like i know that guy right
that's what it seems like and if that's
the case and they share a hive mind
spider-man 3 is still in continuity sad
face but it means that like the whole
multiversal concept is intact that the
knowledge of the venom symbiote as it
was bonded to topher grace and
spider-man 3 that information is shared
with the entire hive mind which includes
the venom symbiote as it's bonded to
eddie brock what does that mean they're
aware of each other they don't have you
don't have to go through the whole thing
of like hey i'm venom and now let's do a
great big huge thing where we meet and
it goes on for half an hour and all that
kind of stuff no no it's one of these
things where like tom hardy meets tom
holland and the venom symbiote just
fills him in like that like oh yeah this
guy's spider-man he can do some stuff
he's a good guy he's cool don't worry
about him he's on our side done and done
right they go forward as teammates you
don't need a 15-minute exposition
explaining who spider-man is to eddie
brock venom fills that in for him right
so this is cool man this is this is a
huge this is huge this is colossal it's
absolutely massive the most exciting
thing to happen to the marvel cinematic
universe really in a long time if i'm
being honest with you guys right sony's
universe is crossing over with the
marvel cinematic universe
man
what a time to be alive with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace